don't care about you or me hahahaha
but about your people bbbbb
it's just another day you bad
[__] uncle Joey is swinging
dick and giving our birthday candles
your [__] it's a beautiful day to be
alive the sun's not shining the clouds
are out it's about the rain but who
gives a [__] I'm 54 what I think 30
years ago I'd still be a [__] no I'm a
no [__]
I don't give a French kiss [__] for my
birthday I got up early with the family
we had a little breakfast I went to
jujitsu on my 54 birthday this you know
why cuz when I quit martial arts I was
15 on my birthday and it was the worst
day of my life so now I'm my birthday I
made sure I do [__] martial arts
double-time some people gonna come over
we're gonna cut a Carvel cake it's
tradition and then I'm one other dinner
with my daughter then I'll see you
[__] ten o'clock at the Comedy
Store for my 20th anniversary set I'm
gonna bomb I'm [__] principled you
understand me but Joey what's with the
chitter chatter that sparked this
[__] soldier
look at that clouds or [__] debt
we got perennials whatever the [__] this
is perennial and we got [__]
perennial presidential to [__]
savages coming at you on the Lord's Day
you understand me just cuz it's my
birthday oh man don't do dick I'm
getting a podcast ready for my main man
tomorrow night 8 o'clock Danny Brown
without a frown smoking and drinking
drinking and smoking are you [__]
kidding me or what we'll get booze we're
doing it all method a method adieu halt
and company [__] beside that I'm
gonna write my goals down for a week I
did my push-ups
I did my protein shake and that's it
mother [__] I'm gonna reread the war
vote for you [__] or the art of
war whatever the [__] it is not sensu
but the other one Steven Pressfield will
give my [__] mind right cuz we're
taking a deep into the murky waters you
understand me
I got that one for you the [__] is going
on today we're blowing clouds like a
[__] you understand me hey let
me ask you something the [__] was that
LSU
you bought bubbles as a kid he's back in
town he wants your [__] number how's
that one for you anyway
there you go just to let you
[__] know what time it is you
understand me uncle Joey here weather
Sunday Monday Wednesday were puffing
we're doing our goals which could be the
best we could be if you [__] up you
always got the next day no big deal
let's do a bowl this presidential to
show these [__] oh yeah my man
George real quick get a little cafe
Elaine and we get this party [__]
started understand I got a bag adaboost
courtesy of star one dispose a debt I
also got a bag Hannibal some [__]
sunset herb I love my peeps down there
my girls a [__] smoke and go down a
sunset I believe that stars they got
[__] the transmission fluid take a
[__] what's the other one that the
moon bars were you to see the devil and
his cousin they got everything but die
dad tell him uncle Joey said [__] and
get yourself right you've been slipping
the last couple [__] weeks
we're taking a deep in the murky waters
like uncle Joey's 54 birthday
don't forget Minneapolis like a
[__] Thursday night the 23rd be
there or [__] shoot yourself you
understand me it's gonna be cold now
what else you gonna do with your [__]
life Minneapolis and surrounding areas
if you have Canada get the [__] raft
come over beside that I love you
[__] thank you very much for
the birthday wishes its obverse one of
the best birthdays I [__] had is
basically because of you [__]
cuz you're solid like the Rock of
Gibraltar like my main man [__]
Puerto Rican Nelson over there there you
go
a little smoke led to your heart until
your mind uncle Joey got you don't
forget the podcast eight o'clock
tomorrow night Thursday Minneapolis CD
still on iTunes but listen I'm here for
you [__] I know you're there
for me that's why we're family I don't
like the word fan fans are for [__]
punks we're a [__] Church family
don't you ever [__] forget that you
understand me and that's it and that's
that have a great day thank you for
everything I love you [__]
don't forget to write your goal just cuz
it's your birthday don't mean you that's
the day you really lock that [__] down
so you come out your birthday we come
out the jump sling and dick and give it
our golf drops alright have a great day
I'll see your [__] later